yang en banlieue de séoul ce n'est que
la deuxième ville en importance pourtant
elle dispose d'un métro aérien qui
ferait l'envi des grandes métropoles un
trait qui faute de passagers ne compte
qu'une seule voiture
au début on pensait que ce serait un
métro mais le très léger de yang in là
qu'une seule voiture alors on pourrait
dire que c'est comme nos autobus
politique un autobus qui pourrait coûter
jusqu'à 3 milliards et demi de dollars
sur 30 ans aux contribuables en incluant
l'entretien
la ville a choisi ce système proposé par
un consortium mené par bombardier parce
que les fonctionnaires avaient prévu 183
mille passagers par jour et un
achalandage tellement gonflée qu'on peut
même dire que cette farce les incrétines
malines lei or à la mise en service en
il n'y avait que neuf mille passagers
l'unité spéciale dans kate l'équivalent
coréen de notre hupac a enquêté sur ce
projet en ppp leur rapport que nous
avons obtenus soutien bombardier a
offert des cadeaux et des voyages aux
fonctionnaires qui ont recommandé sa
technologie
les élus de la ville de yongin n'était
pas en reste et en ramenant motors entre
2003 et 2005
bombardier a payé trois voyages au
canada à 37 personnes billets d'avion en
classe affaire golf tourisme et hôtels
luxueux 18 d'entre elles étaient membres
du conseil municipal de yongin l'unité
spéciale d' enquête appelle cela de la
corruption
mais ce vice président chez bombardier
rejette complètement cette allégation
en fait ce peuple un voyage d'agrément
il ya des besoins de convaincre ces gens
alors que la technologie fonctionne bien
si c'était de la corruption
il nous aurait poursuivi l'enquète
avance aussi que bombardier aurait
constitué un fonds clandestins de deux
millions de dollars pour le canadien qui
mcbeal son représentant en corée une
somme qui aurait servi à faire du
lobbying pour d'autres projets est ce
que moi je fume fait qu'on n'a pas fait
de paiements illicites en au port payer
de pots-de-vin
il n'y a pas eu d'accusations en raison
de l'expiration des délais selon les
procureurs coréens ou du manque de
preuves selon bombardier
mais le projet très suscite la colère
chez ceux que nous avons rencontrés
une arnaque à la limite de la légalité
c'est ce que je pense et ont créé l'euro
alors que la ville de yongin coupes dans
ses programmes sociaux pour rembourser
sa dette
bombardier continue à tirer profit du 13
la vie lui verse 20 millions de dollars
par année pour le contrat de gestion et
d'entretien
il faut dire marie maude que cette
histoire en corée du sud vous l'avez
découverte en enquêtant sur le slr
système léger sur rail qui prévu sur le
pont champlain ici à vauvert oui parce
que le train vous avez vu le reportage
ce trailer c'est très précisément un
métro de surface automatisé céline et ça
peut faire une grosse différence
bombardier en a vendu notamment à kuala
lumpur à l'aéroport jfk à new york et à
vancouver c'est le train qui roule
principalement sur le réseau du skytrain
mais on s'est intéressé à cette
technologie là en particulier et à
bombardier en enquêtant sur tout le
processus et solaire sur le pont
champlain un gros projet dont on parle
beaucoup ces temps ci une investissement
de 5 milliards avec la caisse de dépôt
qui pourrait décider d'investir dans le
projet et on a découvert des choses qui
vont être intéressants pour le public
pour comprendre quels sont les gros
intérêts en jeu dans ce projet là on va
avoir des révélations assez surprenante
demain notamment sur l'achalandage prévu
pour le trait alors on se rabat sans
faute à l'émission enquête demain un
train nommé délire
intéressant comme petite mercy margot